i had a twitter bio for the last few
months i just changed it but i know i
thought it was good 10 million rev or
something i basically said every twitter
bio i ever saw was like the past
and i thought
okay i see the value in that like it's
good for somebody to land and know what
you're doing but i thought what's more
interesting is like what are you trying
to do now i said how could i plant my
flag just in the
top of my profile and it was very
controversial i think a lot of people
felt i i don't know they don't tell me
but i'm i'm assuming there are there are
a bunch of people out there who probably
read it was like this is kind of cringy
or like why is he saying this is weird
and there's some people that would deal
with what was it
all you did was said i want to make a
hun no the business will do 10 million
in revenue this year i said three things
i said four things i said
i'm trying to be in a great mood daily
yeah i'm going to get into phenomenal
shape for the first time in my life
i'm going to make 10 million dollars by
december
and i'm going to um
i remember what my last one was uh
something else but those are the three
there's something about fitness maybe
the second one is getting phenomenal
shape for the first time that and uh
something else maybe it was like i don't
know
blah blah family something to make me
sound good after i said i want 10
million bucks by december okay so
i put that out there and i got
i would say
five really important messages from
there of like really great connections
that came out of it from people just
being like yo like respect i respect you
for putting that there
uh i i might be able to help you with
the fitness thing i might be able to
help you with i see you have the mood
thing what are you doing for that i want
to learn i'm like great i would love to
teach it um or
10 million bucks how you plan to do it
how far along are you come on i get an
email from one guy he keeps saying how
far long are you getting close your
thing is inspiring me my i set my goal
too my goal is not 10 million my goal is
100 000 but i want to make 100 000. and
so like it attracts like-minded people
um and i and i i don't even think that
that was that good of one version of
this i think the the law 25 you just
said is super important to like
continuously reinvent and craft it and
like play with it um don't get stuck in
like whatever you used to say three
years ago or even three months ago
necessarily if it's no longer the the
most badass exciting fun version of you
and what you're trying to do
do you um and what does it say now you
want to build a hundred million dollar
brand or something yeah i started
building a hundred million dollar brand
and
i put that i'm investing in company
badass companies like xyz